good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toes
happy
Friday I think I like this little life
Claudia cannot stop singing that do you
know what that is it's a sound yeah it's
like the sound people are using on
social media to like put videos to like
little Clips together of like how
amazing their life is but like the the
community on Tik Tok like they've turned
it on its head and now if you use it
like it's so cringey like everybody's
making fun of it I think I like this
little lie so are you you're now on the
for lack of a better word it's an
offensive word but like the bandwagon of
ticktockers making fun of the sound I'm
on the bandwagon of like whatever is
cool at the moment like I have no
Scruples I have absolutely no principles
I have no spine like whatever everyone
says I agree I agree too but you know
what is cool at the
moment let me think us yeah the toast
Chucky at the moment the toast is is
busing at at all moments it's true it's
true but in this moment in particular
because we're back yesterday was the
first show of the Year everyone was so
excited and then yesterday afternoon I
was just sitting around minding my
business and you know what it came to me
as I was mining my own business oh our
seventh season theme song seventh heaven
when I see those happy faces smiling
back at me S Heaven do you remember
literally never heard this song in my
life you would and I was surprised no
one commented it and I didn't even have
to Google it it just came to me like are
you sure are you sure you're not making
it up I'm pretty sure I maybe I should
have Googled like the whole lyrics
because honestly I don't know a lot but
I do know that this sounds like a madeup
song seven s like it sounds fake because
the show is
fake that is true it's not real family
it was no of course it was a drama but
like the show itself like was 7th Heaven
in the simulation stand off in the
comments I'm so glad she brought this up
7th Heaven Wasn't
real I feel like it was a mirage and
maybe something that like we invented in
our childhood I did want to Circle back
to something you brought up which was
yesterday's episode oh okay yeah and I
want you to ask me how many times I
watched yesterday's episode how many
times did you watch yesterday's episode
twice like I never even watch it once it
was so good I was cackling I told all my
friends I'm like you guys you have to
listen to this podcast it's so good like
we were really on one yesterday we were
just being hysterical we had all this
like pent
up energy and like communication yeah so
good was there anything in particular
that made you chuckle that maybe you
know what always happens to me I loved
our Gypsy Rose there's so many
conversations that like we have them and
we laugh but then if I ever watch
episode back there are like nuggets that
I like kind of missed while I was
sitting here and I'm like hey that was
funny I told my friend Abe I'm like you
have to watch a toast he's like I always
do I'm like yeah but like you really
have to listen so he called me after he
watched and he goes and he like brought
something up that like I didn't even
notice he was like the name on
everybody's lips this holiday season is
Gypsy Rose
Blanchard and I was like yeah the name
on everybody slips this holiday season
is Gypsy Rose Blanchard you have a
problem hysterical stuff but just like
past hysterical stuff just didn't even
get a
mention didn't even get a mention like
we are we're genuinely like too funny
for our own good there's just like too
many funny moments can't even
process I think I like this little life
you know yeah you should make a video I
think I like this little life I think I
like this honestly can somebody clip
this audio and like let's replace it
with the I think I like this little life
and then and then it be like a
montage and then it should be a montage
of like you and I chuckling for sure for
sure but like you just cut onto oh I
ruin the audio okay yeah okay ready sh
I'm going to enjoy my
shake I think I like this little
life this little life oh now you're
shaking your Shake on my audio oh gosh
oh gosh Okay go again it's fine it's
fine honestly the shake is like so us
we're always doing something so
us um wait I had something else I wanted
to
say I'm sure you have a lot of things to
say it's Friday that's huge major News
Major key to success oh I remember I
wanted to wish a very happy birthday to
kind of like an OG bre number one
toaster friend of the family Margo F
Leen she's a an OG kind of a staple if
you'd listen you know we're always
talking about different margos in our
lives she's one of them today's her
birthday happy birthday love you dearly
happy birthday Margo I was texting her
this morning she and I have been friends
for 24 years wow that'll make you feel
old right that's insane that'll make you
feel old we met when she was eight and I
was seven you're so young well yeah it's
just because otherwise it doesn't make
sense with like the 24 but she's
turning 24 plus 8 and wow not you
putting her on blast and we've been
friends 24 years which she's my oldest
longest friend that is so nice who's my
oldest friend like probably someone from
middle school oh me of course I mean
Olivia is my oldest longest friend yeah
yeah yeah you're my old and I guess I'm
margos but who's margos all three of us
yeah yeah hey
snitch hey Satchel crel you know every
day we'll give you a shout out and hopes
that you
listen yeah this podcast is really us
just trying to get our younger sister's
attention like to try and make it on her
Tik Tok algorithm to try and like get
someone to text her hey did you listen
to the toast in an attempt to get our
sister to like think we're cool we
coincidentally like created this you
know billion dollar Media Company yeah
like Empire the voice of a generation
we're just hoping it reaches her oh my
God speaking of Empire I have three more
episodes left in Gossip Girl I um like I
know what happens in the final episode
and I know that they reveal reveal who
Gossip Girl is but Ben doesn't know so
I'm going to be recording because I
really want to get his
um opinion on it because like a season
ago they like gave you like a little uh
teaser where they pretended like
Georgina was Gossip Girl which actually
was like a good call it should have just
been been like Georgina like an outsider
with in like with computer and a
computer and a voice it made total sense
um but so I that's probably what I'll do
this weekend finish Gossip Girl and then
my next Journey with Ben is the OC I'm
very excited for that and I need to look
up what episode it happens in but like
the I don't want to spoil it but like
the big thing that happens in the OC you
know
yeah where they play uh image in Heap
yeah I'll record Ben's reaction to that
too wow yeah he's ever seen it isn't
that crazy that is crazy I'm excited for
him to find out who Gossip Girl is I
know I don't think he really cares like
what if I just texted him right now and
said blank is Gossip
Girl
um that would be insane so I actually
you just reminded me I
think I think I told Ben who Gossip Girl
was like as a joke and he was like no
way I'm like no I'm kidding but like it
was
I think I did that either like I thought
about doing it or I actually did it I
can never remember if things are real or
they're just my thoughts just like
seventh heaven exactly classic tury who
did you most relate to in seventh heaven
because like I really obviously like
wanted to be a Jessica beel but like we
all knew I was a Beverly Mitchell you
know
yeah I'll tell you one thing I wasn't
the dad no we were not the dad you are
not the father
you are not the father yeah I didn't I
didn't see myself reflected in the show
well that makes sense because it was
like a house full of Christians and
we're like Jewish and I couldn't relate
to the show on any singular level but
there are a lot of similarities in
judeo-christian values I guess that's
true like family values traditional
energy yeah no that's so fair yeah but
they were just like these like you know
blonde blueeyed like playing basketball
in the yard like that wasn't going to be
us ever no no certainly not the
basketball no no certainly not going to
church I guess it's Beverly Mitchell cuz
and because you and I are both middle
children middle children girls like
obviously I didn't relate to any of the
boys Jessica be is like the oldest and
then there was the young girl which were
neither of those so we are both Beverly
Mitchell I think we're all Beverly
Mitchell we are but Jessica beel was
also just like you know older but she
really was also like fully developed for
lack of a better word and like she had
really come into herself and she was
like beautiful and young like no I was
not going to be relating to that
character because we were like seven
hagard yeah yeah we were just what
channel was that we were little girls
was it ABC family or wb11 those were the
only two we watched it was G giving ABC
family that's a great call yeah rip ABC
Family rip that was a mistake I don't
know free form does good stuff the Bold
type the type of bold I want you to sit
on something because before 2024 I the
end of last year you and I discussed
potentially creating a new segment on
the
show okay and that segment would be on
Fridays which is today dear farmer
that's no no and that segment would be
weenie of the week okay okay where we
give the title to either someone we know
in our lives someone in in pop culture
who did something particularly weenie
esque this week okay um now we've only
had two episodes this week so there's
not a lot to discuss but I think we
should try it if it doesn't work we'll
cancel it like unburden yourselves was a
segment that just didn't work it's okay
to admit fault to admit defeat I think
this has potential so I want to in I
want to put it in your brain now and at
the end of the F fast five stories we
will do our inaugural very first weenie
of the week segment and we'll have the
toaster vote in the comments for who
they thought was the bigger weenie mine
or yours okay but like what if we didn't
talk about them on the toast just for
for one reason or another it could be
kind of how like Ben and Josh on Good
Guys do like what are you nuts it's not
something that happened on the show like
something that happened to you in real
life like this freak at the doctor's
office you know like it could be
anything okay okay cool one name comes
to mind early on but we show is it me no
but it's similar to your
name
Claudia Gloria Claudine gay oh okay oh
that's good too yeah it's kind of like
Jack hole you know like Andy's I I know
what Wy of the week is I grew up on it
okay right after I'm talking talking
about the segment I'm talking about like
the segment yeah no no I got it I got it
okay that's so I'm excited about that so
just like I don't I don't have my
selection yet yet but hopefully it'll
come to me throughout the stories like I
I I'd like to do someone in popular
culture this week not someone in my
personal life nobody offended me in my
personal life this week no I would not
put someone on my personal life on blast
like unless were you oh like if Ben did
something really lame I would give a
meaning of the week like no there are
enough villainous bad faith actors out
there not the bad faith actors what
about bad faith actor of the week by the
way obsessed Jackie you guys if you only
knew how frequently in our personal
lives Jackie and I use the term bad
faith actors it is so funny and it is so
stupid and it is like the worst phrase
ever when you use it in a serious way
like people who like write scholarly
literature like using the phrase bad
faith actors like in a serious way we're
using it ironically it's so funny cuz
you're a bad faith actor you're acting
in bad faith well that is what bad faith
actors do so let me know if you also
want to add BFA of the W be a [__]
that's like kind of better no nothing
but like we of the week like harks back
to our childhood and it really just
rolls off the tongue BFA like really
doesn't roll off the tongue vote in the
comments no no or give us like uh we
have to rephrase it bad faith actor of
the week like it's not right like bad
faith actor Friday or something you
know bad faith actor Friday it's still
not great no it's not great we can
Workshop it I think wey of the week it
really resonated with people when we
shared it and like I think that's what
it is but alternate title like maybe in
other countries weenie doesn't translate
it could be bad faith actor of the
week okay I like that for our Global
[Laughter]
audience love that love love love love
hearts oh by the way somebody called out
something so interesting about
yesterday's episode like we were off for
a month we came back we talked about
everything under the sun and we
literally didn't even mention Taylor and
Travis they were quiet this month no
they weren't they were like having their
holiday they had their New Year's kiss
it's like either we talk about them the
whole we're all or nothing about them
like and it's like we couldn't come back
and talk all about Taylor and Travis
especially when there was like some
other big news like Natalia Grace's real
age and like Gypsy Rose is a free woman
right like there was Major things to
talk about and so I don't in deciding
not to add it to the stories it's like
we don't talk about it at all and if it
is in the stories we talk about it for
30 minutes so yeah that that happened
it's really All or Nothing when it comes
to Tavis another cringy line so that
happened oh I love that that's like you
and Dana love to do this thing where you
like will um kind of round up like the
cringiest most popular captions that
people do cringy is like social media
tropes okay so that's one of them yeah
so I did a thing I did a thing yeah
that's what are the others well Dana's
big pet peeve is when people personify
places so like New York City Barcelona
has my heart New York City you look good
this morning oh hate yeah that really
and also she also hates when people are
on vacation and they write like never
leaving it's like girl you have your
return flight booked you are leaving
that okay like that one if you're like a
stickler for facts like I understand
that one doesn't bother me as much but
New York you look good today like
seriously death jail but like the thing
is you are leaving unless you're not
leaving then then you're never leaving
say it you know it would be it would be
better to be like I never want to leave
like I me neither you know I get it yeah
no I you're literally returning tomorrow
night no you had to plan to return
before you even arrived before you even
wrote that caption right so those are
some of Dana's pepp peeves that I've
taken on and now I can't unsee them yeah
yeah yeah shout out Dana shout out Dana
should we dive in the stories today I
did choose since Jax was you know busy
this morning being a mother of two and I
just say I really don't like knowing
what the stories are like I love being
on the edge of your seat and people
always ask like do you really not know
what jackon is going to say I really
don't and like I know it's coming today
and it's like not as fun the suspense
has been you know ruined yeah it was a
tur's choice choice choice was a tur
chice it's a choice choice choice choice
choice
choice oh I'm so glad you brought that
up um because I was thinking a lot this
morning how
frightening and I was feeling
sick and I was feeling feeling
tired sick and tired yeah because I I
stumbled across a video on Tik Tok of uh
Leon Meer singing summer girls from
Country Strong Amazon posted it I guess
to promote that like country strong is
on Prime video so it's my new comedy
special lean in and the comments were
just like oh my God Leon Meer was in a
movie what is this like it was so
disappointing and honestly like I was
really let down nobody knowing this film
not only not knowing it never seeing it
like I feel really exhausted like
putting this
this task it's it's been on our backs
for years and it's like no one will help
why do people not care about this movie
like it's insane it is insane but that's
why we have to do the work and you guys
need to educate yourselves you do and
like when I see people like standing a
Stars board with Lady Gaga and Bradley
Cooper which don't get me wrong like was
a good movie
and they don't even know like that there
was a movie before
that that did it better that did it
better like similar premise countryfied
like it just really makes me sick and it
makes me annoyed like the casting
Garrett had L gwenith palro Tim McGraw
Lon Meer the soundtrack tomin is
everything like gwenneth pal
like I'm just like I'm tired and I'm
like I'm I'm done yeah that's why you
should stay off of Tik Tok there is
really disgusting things happening there
and this is just one of them this is
what people are always talking about
when they say like Tik Tok is bad yeah
Tik Tok is poisoning the youth except
I'm glad that Prime video is stepping up
to the plate joining our think it was
Amazon freey freey like they're turn new
platform No freie like is wiling its way
in jury duty yeah and they're like free
v i don't love the name but it lets you
know that it's free V it's free videos
yeah no I get it no I I like what
they're doing you'd rather see them up
there shaking that thing I would and I
do sometimes and I can watch Country
Strong there good to know cuz I'm
Country
Strong Heart
Break like the gr like original music
like you know you you're tasteless
you're classless if you don't watch that
movie yeah I had one more question to
pose to the comments because I've been
seeing salurn everywhere like oh oh oh
I'm so glad you brought this all I see
is salurn and I have the privilege of
having absolutely no idea what's it
about is Jeremy Allen White in it I
think no okay I don't know it I don't I
don't okay Jacob a now you guys know me
and you know what I like
no% you should not watch this movie
should I watch this movie sound off in
the comments without telling me anything
about it cuz I want to go in blind if I
do watch it so I don't know anything
about it either I know it's the second
half of the movie do I don't even want
to know what it a word to describe it I
don't even want to know well then you're
not going to be able to make a decision
no I don't want to make a decision I
want someone to tell me you guys know me
should I watch the movie Jackie
absolutely should not watch this movie
okay like absolutely not okay okay I
guess I'm not watching no you're
definitely not and if you would let me
finish a sentence you would know why and
you would immediately know watcha okay
tell me it's like extremely disturbing
graphic like um sexually like you would
not why is everyone being like Oh my
gosh salurn hehe best movie they're not
saying he he best movie they're saying
oh my God salurn what the [__] did I
just watch no but like it's also but
it's like not in the don't watch this
sort of way no because you know it's
like the Curiosity of the mind like oh
it's disturbing what what could possibly
be so bad we've all seen Game of Thrones
like no it's like crazy you know what it
is
so I know that there's like two I no no
I don't want to know what it is do you
know what it is it's yes or no question
no no I know one you it is yes or
no half yes and no I know I know one
thing that happens yeah it's like
something in the graveyard I don't know
I yeah like it's up for you okay glad
glad I asked the question cuz you're a
business owner you're a mom of two like
I know your time is precious I wouldn't
recommend you watch that CU I was just
like I was saying to Zach I was like
have you heard about Sal bir and he was
like no what's that I'm like I don't
really know either maybe we should just
like watch it like blind this weekend oh
my God no Jackie like you definitely
shouldn't I was thinking about watching
it with Ben cuz like I keep finding like
weird things to watch and making Ben
watch it with me and I actually wanted
to do it just so I could seriously
record him that's your favorite thing
yeah I live for I'm a like I live in a
Content house I'm literally the hype
house you do live in a Content house
between you and Ben and your kitchen
yeah like with our new apartment like
there's so much natural light it just
kind of like is begging for content to
be made and I literally wake up and just
like make content and I feel like I'm
Liv like I'm literally Charlie demilio
you are Ben is little hoodie oh my I
almost said Brian Freddy and slip that
makes me
Dixie you are Dixie totally totally
toally wiser older
sister sure Paving her own
way totally that's
Dixie shall we we shall without further
a do here are the stories that tury
decided that you need to know this
morning and I'm so excited because we
have a new sponsor that Jackie's been
talking about forever before they were a
sponsor armra so you guys know that we
are always on the lookout for ways to
strengthen immunity improve Fitness
metabolism Elevate our skin well we
recently discovered an incredible
product armura so I saw it all over
social media like all the cool girls are
all the aesthetic girls all the healthy
girls are doing armra colostrum is the
First Nutrition that we receive in life
and it contains all the essential
nutrients that we need in order to
thrive and armor is a proprietary
concentrate of bovine chrum that
harnesses over 400 functional nutrients
to strengthen your immune your immune
barriers fuel cellular health for a host
of research-backed benefits armor chrom
strengthens immunity and ignites
metabolism it fortifies gut health it
activates hair growth and skin Radiance
and it Powers Fitness performance and
recovery so every like the name on
everybody's lips is actually armor I
know everybody keeps like a packet of it
in their um purse and so I was
influenced like before they became a
sponsor like I just literally I think
bought it off of social media because
everyone was talking about it and it's
really fabulous I love having like
something in my daily routine that I can
do every single day just makes me feel
really um productive and the results are
fabulous especially now that I'm in my
fitness era like I feel a noticeable
difference the results are fabulous you
want to know how I know the results are
fabulous is because I forgot to bring it
with me on the trip and the way I am
falling apart my hands are cracking my
nails I was like bragging that I was
able to sustain like really long nails
every single one of them I had to cut
off because like they started getting so
dry again it's just so great like the
overall benefits can't are inexplicable
yet so noticeable like my hair was
feeling so healthy and what I love about
armor also is you can like do one scoop
two scoop or three scoops it's like a
bioactive ingredient so you kind of can
like beef it up if you feel like you're
on the low which is where I am right now
so typically I would do one scoop a day
but now I'm doing like two or three to
kind of make up for the deficit we've
worked out a great offer for The
Toasters you can receive 15% off your
first order when you go to try armor.com
toast or just enter code toast to get
15% % off your first order that's t r ym
a.com toast today's episode is also
brought to you by poppy it's no secret
that soda has become a dirty word
they're too sugary they're too syrupy we
don't blame you for wanting to leave it
in the past but that era of soda is
officially over I know a lot of people's
resolutions are always like quit soda or
for me it's never quit soda I don't
think that's realistic but I definitely
like want to cut back and especially
with my fitness and health Journey I'm
doing way less soda and Poppy's really
really helpful if you want to supplement
like that delicious just treat at the
end of the day poppy is a better for you
soda made with clean ingredients 5 GRS
of sugar or less and prebiotics yes
they're literally prebiotics in each can
die Coke could never you can feel good
about what's in your can with Poppy's
classic flavors like Cola doc pop root
beer and you can say goodbye to empty
calories artificial ingredients and high
fructose corn syrup the flavors are
busting I'm not going to lie like they
really get as close to Cola Root Beer
flavors as they can like they're really
really good and it's a great supplement
if you're trying to cut back on soda or
cut out soda completely completely their
doc pop flavor tastes just like Dr
Pepper and of course their Cola tastes a
lot like Coke they have fresh fruit
flavors like strawberry lemon cherry
limeade orange and grape they're
bursting with flavors and you can shop
poppy on Amazon for 15% off with code
toast 15 off in retailers Nationwide you
can also shop but if you want to use
that code toast5 off go to Poppy on
Amazon and get 15% off if you're a die
Coke early and like one of your
resolutions is to cut back this year I
feel you I see you like one thing at a
time try the cola flavor it really it is
helpful and it's just so much better for
you like you'll feel less lethargic and
less honestly for me like gassy
throughout the day um so thanks poppy
thanks
poppy are you ready for our first story
yeah we're diving in after having our
blinders on because the golden Bachelor
had his golden wedding last night golden
Bachelor Gary Turner married spoiler
alert we're just going to rip it off
Teresa nist um last night at La Resort
and Club it was a live televised wedding
filled so I only I only just recently
put that together like I knew that the
wedding was airing yesterday and I
didn't realize like the wedding was also
happening yesterday it's kind of a crazy
thing I didn't know any of this was
happening except for following Raven
Gates and I was watching her stories
yesterday and she said I'm going to La
for a wedding I was like how lovely then
later in the day she was like it's being
filmed it's Gary and Teresa's wedding I
was like oh my God they're getting
married right now and it's live and and
it's crazy don't you ever just sit back
and think because at least I do that you
are like so similar to Raven Gates do
you think about that a lot in like just
like our life trajectory like you both
married guys from Dallas she lives in
Dallas you have two children literally
both both children born like the same
week yeah like her kids are the exact
same distance apart as mine and they're
they're one month ahead of us though no
you guys just remind me a lot of each
other no I relate to her content a lot
that's why I'm always watching with
sound on yeah so then I knew what she
was up to and that's how I learned about
all of this and also about Gary a lot of
the bachelor couples and Bachelor
favorites were in attendance like and it
was crazy to see like who are this The
long-standing Bachelor couples so it's
like Raven and Adam Jade and Tanner
Ashley and Jared kayn and Kaitlin yeah
and then I saw Caitlyn Bristo and Tesa
were there but like there's drama right
okay I don't know if there's drama like
between Caitlyn and tasa I know there's
drama between Caitlyn and her Instagram
followers but I don't know if like TAA
is mad basically for anybody who like
doesn't know I didn't know I only know
what you and Margo briefly told me when
I asked Caitlyn Bristo had a uh New
Year's Eve party at her house a lot of
Bachelor people were there including
Zack Clark who one tasa season was
engaged to tasa um but obviously they
are no longer together after running a
marathon they they couldn't make it
relatable then um a lot of people like
saw footage CU it was like a lot of
reality stars and just people posting
content from this party people saw just
like a a couple instances where I think
maybe Zach's arm was around Caitlin like
No No Smoking Gun could have just been
very friendly types of you know
behaviors um and you know bachelor
Nation went after Caitlyn for that for
one dating someone that tasa used to
date due two I guess like dating someone
in recovery you know that's like his
full-time job he runs recovery centers
he's really involved in like the sober
community and Caitlyn you know her she
is a brand of wine and like wine is a
big part of like her wine culture is a
big part of her brand so people are like
that's appropriate and they just like
came for her for literally everything is
pro went off is there any proof that
they're dating no like we don't even
know if this is confirmed okay cuz like
if they're that's what Kayla was saying
she was like you guys know nothing right
so I mean if they're not dating this is
a moood point but like even if they are
dating and she is a wno and he's a sober
person like why are you guys acting like
he doesn't have agency over like his
life and who he chooses to date and that
like yeah I just I have to imagine she
wouldn't have responded if they're not
dating do you know what I mean you're
not dating so so you think they are
dating I do and I also feel like tasa
doesn't care yeah like I honestly like I
think tasa liked him but I think she
like stayed engaged him for as long as
it was like appropriate after after the
show she was single for a little bit and
now she's been in a relationship for a
long time with Luke from summerhouse
like oh they're in a real relationship
oh yeah I don't know if this is bad but
like I just saw them at the Jet game
cute yeah like they're fully together
they're always spotted together yeah I
did see a couple pictures but I didn't
realize like it was you know I didn't
realize how many times I've seen a
couple pi pictures over how long yeah
they're together yeah no and tia I feel
like I know her kind of and I think
she's like a real like girls girl like I
think she would be really happy if these
two like were in love like honestly cuz
she's so happy in her life right now I
think yeah I don't think she would be
mad she doesn't seem like that type of
girl got it okay well I just like saw
that they were together but I didn't see
them like together though I just saw on
Raven's Instagram she was with tan and
she was with Caitlyn yeah yeah so they
were both at the wedding honestly I
don't think there's beef but I I have no
information like I'm just guessing I
have no information but if Caitlyn and
Zach are together I could see
that I don't know if I could see it like
I was shocked by the pairing of those
two you
know I I I know what you say I
understand these words but I don't
necessarily agree back to your point I
agree with you that it's really
interesting to see who like ABC and the
bachelor franchise like keep in the fold
and who they consider to be like their
stars and the obviously if you're a
couple and you're still together like
you still you should get invited of
course but it definitely is interesting
to see who you know was Jade roer
Tolbert there yes of course of course
she's like a she's a star of the
franchise yeah was like Nick vile there
I feel like they love having him around
and like Ben Higgins Ben Higgins was
there I saw I don't know if Nick vile
was he definitely was Heely he
definitely was he lives in town he lives
in town he literally is like the go-to
reality TV podcast right like these days
right right like anytime any sort of
reality show blows up like whether it be
Netflix like they go on his show but he
didn't post anything he has no stories
up let's I don't think so I want to see
like a Roundup Bachelor Stars that's
like you know US Weekly lives for this
sort of article right who were at the
wedding and it is
Gary I can't go down this road again I
really can't well on her story Raven
said
Gary okay see every I don't think that
that makes it a confirmation I don't see
she just listens to the toast see every
Bachelor Nation Star who made Gary
weddings wedding Gary
weddings okay I don't know these people
um oh Michelle Young and Jack Lewis I
don't know if this obviously her
boyfriend I don't know if he's a
bachelor person but Michelle and her man
okay these two people I don't know if
they were ever on The Bachelor they
might be like new um tasa kayn oh Dean
dyed his hair
Dean looked hot he was wearing this hat
like he looked hot uh Zach shellcross
and Katie bigger he was The Bachelor is
this his chosen woman oh the most recent
Zach yeah wow irrelevant they look in
love in this picture oh Trista and Ryan
and their kids yes yes their kids are
like grown grown Ben Higgins Ashley I
Patty James Matt James's mom did she go
on oh she was a contestant she was a
contestant love that that's cute oh
Kenny from um Seasons past he was the
boy band
manager because also he was in a
high-profile couple for a while I don't
know if they're still together but when
he went on Paradise that girl I forget
her name but they were together oh here
she is Marie I guess they're still
together I find it shocking that like
Matt and Tyler weren't there I feel like
they're like the biggest stars of
Bachelor Nation right now it's crazy if
Matt wasn't there and his mom was and
he's still with Rachel from his season
they should be there do you think that
Bachelor Nation like consider I mean
like the powers that be at the bachelor
production do you think they consider
Matt and Rachel like a a couple that's
like in the green or like with with with
the bachelor with the powers that be
like you're either like sanctioned or
you're not like you get invited to stuff
and you get opportunities Dancing with
the Stars or like you're like in the red
zone and like nobody wants to talk to
you and I feel like there was all that
drama with Matt and Rachel but they
literally like so in love I mean I the
fact that his mom is like on the show
probably means they have good feelings
towards one another but after took that
bus and ran over them right um I don't
know if they're if on both ends if
they're willing
to I had another thought accept but I
think if if Matt's mom is on the show
like it's obviously fine I had another
thought isn't it kind of crazy like cuz
Matt and Rachel like won The Bachelor
but they're not
engaged it's crazy by standards but like
not for their age and no no just because
of the bachelor yeah like technically
they've been dating for 3 years so
normal so normal they're like such a
cute couple agreed
um other names well congrats Gary
congrats grads and Terry and Terry Terry
and Gary Terry and Gary cute I still
want to watch golden Bachelor I'm so
glad they got married like to me the
proof is in the pudding these were two
people who were like serious as much as
you want to slander Gary and drag his
name around town like he wanted to find
love and get married and have his next
chapter and that's what he did he's a
man of his word so like I hope you're
eating their words I hope everyone is
eating their words I'm also just
relieved that like the attempt to take
Gary down didn't work no it it couldn't
work yeah no like sometimes these like
insane social media campaigns like
actually make waves and I'm so glad this
one did
not
yeah yeah yeah are you ready for our
next story yeah Kelly Clarkson jokes
that her stylists only want to put her
in tight [__] after her weight loss so
Kelly Clarkson is a skinny Legend after
joking about her weight loss at a Las
Vegas residency performance of her show
chemistry in a fan recorded video shared
on Tik Tok she interacted with lucky
fans before taking a shot with someone
celebrating their birthday uh she could
Kelly Clarkson takes shots I know she's
so versatile no I think that's crazy she
couldn't really move around in her drums
she said oh boy I really can't bend in
these dude this is tight like I lost
weight and my styling team is like let's
get you into this tight [__] still she
successfully grabbed and down the shot
to the Delight of her cheering fans one
of whom called her a skinny Legend okay
like Kelly Clarkson has lost weight do I
care no for me like the major story here
is Kelly Clarkson is finally wearing
normal clothes and that was just
something like we all kind of like
didn't talk about like for a really long
time especially when she was promoting
chemistry like she was dressing like a
grandmother you know at Woodstock I
don't know what the vibe was it was so
weird and it was just a kind of like
this crazy quirky thing about Kelly and
it's clear that in the New Year not even
in the new year because it happened like
towards the end of the year she got a
new stylist who just started dressing
her and like it's not even gorgeous
things it's like things you could buy at
the mall but like it's good it's better
and I'm grateful yeah I'm looking at
some of these photos and I even think in
this new I don't know which are the old
and which are the new and yeah I guess
like Kelly Clarkson we could go on the
record like Kelly Clarkson doesn't have
the best style but no and for a while
she had bad style but like do you think
that's part of her brand of being like
relatable like if she was like this
glamour pus style Queen maybe she
wouldn't touch the hearts of all of us
like she has okay so I'm so glad you
brought that up because yes she cannot
be a glamazon like it's just it's the
antithesis of everything that she does
she's a she's like America's Queen she's
so relatable you know what they say you
know feed the masses dine with the
classes like that's Kelly however in her
new styling era like I just said it's
not gorgeous Glam Amazon it's good it's
stuff you buy at the mall it's
acceptable it's passible by no means is
it giving Runway like Kelly Clarkson is
not going to the maala and that's why we
love her and that's why we love her and
if she ever were to go to the maala
which I actually feel like she will she
lives in New York now and she's yeah
actually she should it doesn't get more
aist than Kelly Clarkson it's so true
and it doesn't get more but but like
everything Kelly stands for is the
antithesis of the meala meala is like
exclusive ity it's like not fun it's so
serious Kelly is free she's open to
everyone like everyone can can watch the
Kelly Clark and show like she's for
everyone it's she's really the opposite
she shouldn't go no I would hope that if
she got an invitation she would know it
would be in the best interest of her
brand to not go but like how do you say
no to the meala like you can't I think
she could if anyone could it's Kelly
yeah or find a way to make it like kify
it you know take us with her like make
it relatable yeah no she needs to like
go with um like every now and then
there's like a crazy brand that buys a
table at the macala like remember on
Instagram bought one like yeah we need
Kohl's or no uh we need Wayfair cuz
that's Kelly we need Wayfair to buy a
table at the mecella and then Kelly can
go yeah and like she'll like you know
take her shoes off on the like something
just like relatable Jennifer lweny
Jennifer lweny yeah has Jennifer
Lawrence been on the Kell Clarkson
show I feel like when she was promoting
no hard feelings maybe yeah maybe for as
much as I love Kelly I don't I don't
watch the show that often I guess I
don't really watch any shows let alone
at like 4:00 no for as much as we love
Kelly I've never watched a show but I've
never scrolled past one of their one of
the clips yeah online ever like I watch
every single clip no and like when I
ever I'm somewhere like at the nail
salon and it's playing like I always
enjoy it jolly good time and I'm always
thinking wow this Kelly is there
anything she can't do there isn't
anything she can't do
there isn't anything she can't do
there's nothing she can't do it's double
negative yeah I love double negatives
that's like the one thing I learned in
like English grammar class that really
actually stuck with me you know what you
are double negative because you're so
negative that you're
positive Jackie I that's I need to
figure out how to reward that like
that's my Housewives tagline like that's
so like that's me that's the essence of
me that's the essence of you it's like
so many negatives that add up to you
being
positive I love I love feeling seen and
understood on a Friday Lally literally
so all that to say whoever is styling
Kelly Clarkson like they're doing a very
good job like the jumpsuit that she wore
in this video is like it looks great on
Kelly it was cool three years ago which
is so on brand for Kelly Clarkson yeah
I'm going to check out the video quickly
it's like from revolve literally from
three years ago I'm not logged into Tik
Tok you're Jackie you're going to
recognize the jumpsuit like oh okay it's
classic and that's it's perfect it's
perfect just like the woman herself
exactly our next story Jeremy Allen
White Strips down to his underwear while
eating an apple for a new Calvin Klein
campaign is this everyone so people
yesterday when I did my box of like what
to talk about they're like Jeremy Allen
White is this why we need to talk about
him and his Apple yeah he's the new face
of Calvin Klein which is like always a
big deal you know the Mark Wahlberg one
is like a famous One Michael B Jordan
like it's always like a really big deal
true and the fact that he chose him they
chose him was really smart um and the
video they put out is just
like what is it like stive him running
around no he's like R he's from Brooklyn
so it's very New York honestly it kind
of looks like the trailer for real
housewi of New York I literally feel
like they were on the same exact Roof oh
he's just sitting here talking I feel
like it's just a classic roof
that like lends itself to studio and
production companies I swear to God it's
the same roof and he's holding an apple
because it's like the big apple he
literally looks like a real housewi of
New York maybe he is maybe it's an
announcement and he's just like working
out and like in this little pair of
white undies and they're really white
and it's like tiny and you know it's
provocative and it's making waves and
I'm sure the collection did really well
when it launched
yesterday and it's just kind of like
everything's coming up jery Allen White
these days do you feel that way I do
feel that way and I feel a little left
behind but I'm also like leaving myself
behind I don't I don't want to go in
much the bear and yeah if you've never
seen him in in anything like you might
not get it not he I mean he has an
amazing body but like he's a short King
and he's not like traditionally like the
most handsome like I don't think like
he's got that like sort of Timeless
classic handsome face he's really very
unique looking and and he always plays
like very sexy roles like in Shameless
he was like this bad boy and he like
[__] his college professor like you you
have to watch him to really get him so
if you haven't watched him I understand
why you feel left behind yeah but I'm
okay being behind like I don't have to
be not everyone is for everything and
every trend is for everyone so that's
fine I'm happy for the Jeremy Allen
White stands and I like and this is a
nice looking campaign I can appreciate
the human
form yeah he's really really handsome um
he's also dating Rosalia cute Kylie's
friend Kylie's friend Rosalia yeah and I
could see that m double Deen because I
could see him friendly with Timothy no
no okay Timothy Kylie Bad Bunny Kendall
Rosalia and Jeremy Allen White like
that's a crew Unstoppable the sexy six
the six chicks the six
chicks obsessed I hope they have a nice
time even though people are saying Bad
Bunny and Kendall like broke up and now
they're back together but then I heard
they got they reconciled like I I
actually like them as a couple I want
when I saw the headline that they broke
up I had a feeling of sadness yeah also
Kendall's a long-term girl like she
makes things work she's really not like
a fling flung you know no but I feel
like she's always in a long-term
relationship that like breaks up once or
twice yeah and then breaks up yeah but I
hope that's not the case here I just
just want to say like this was five
stars to Jeremy Allen White's team for
booking this and five stars to Calvin
Klein for like choosing Jeremy Allen
White I think it's the perfect
partnership and I love when people
actually do good things yeah I agree
it's a nice the pictures are nice
looking um and if anybody who works in
like location scouting can confirm that
this is where they filmed the real the
new real housewise of New York like it
totally is yeah super cute same exact
Skyline are you ready for our next Story
number four yeah how Gypsy Rose
Blanchard feels about ex Nicholas God
John's amid his life in prison sentence
you know I do Wonder we talked about
this yesterday like what's the vibe
what's going on there so the name on
everyone's lips this holiday season is
Gypsy Rose
Blanchard and she's doing the most so
she did an interview with Good Morning
America and she was asked about um
Nicholas she said I'm sure that we both
have a lot of regrets all I can really
say is that I did my time he's doing his
time for his part and I wish him well on
his journey damn she hit him with the
wish you well yeah no it's giving good
day
sir yeah no I I hope for the best for
you it's like goodbye and good riddens
yeah it doesn't appear as though she'll
be keeping in communication with him and
it kind of seems like she's distancing
herself from him which I get you know he
is a murderer however the person he
murdered like was for her I don't know
how you can just like he killed for her
and now he's rotting in prison and she's
married someone new like it's it's a
it's a doggy dog world out there like
look at Gypsy Rose yeah we could all
learn a lot from Gypsy Rose I I agree
and I stand by that yeah she she's got
these men wrapped around her finger no
it's so true also when I read this
article this morning I was shocked
Beyond shocked to learn that Gypsy Rose
is 32 years old what did you think I
don't know I thought she was much
younger I guess because like you know
they say that people become stunted at
the age that they became f so for Gypsy
Rose that would have been like 14 I
really and I guess I didn't realize how
long she was in prison for I I don't
know I would have assumed she was like
22 now like she she did something in her
teens she went to jail for a little bit
you know how long was she in jail like
10 years I think eight
yeah
well and this Gypsy Rose thing is just
like it's it's a moral relativism cuz
like murder is bad right
yeah unless it's like self-defense and
in a way this like was self-defense yeah
with a bit of
Revenge right but it's not like Gypsy
did it this random dude did Ryan yeah no
it there's a lot of moral questions here
that we are asking ourselves but at the
end of the day as Gypsy said she did the
time for the crime and she's not looking
back she's giving tabula rasa maybe
she's listening to the toast she's Clean
Slate new man resolu new man hudis maybe
that's her resolution like leave all
toxic energy in the past yeah she
deserves a tabularasa she does I mean
she did hard
time H she did a hard time
yeah it's like my worst
nightmare well just stay out of trouble
tury Lou by the way I absolutely plan to
like I don't plan on committing any
crimes ever however like I I am afraid
like not that I'm going to be framed or
anything but like you just like your
life changes in a in a Flash like even
if it's self-defense like let's say
somebody breaks into my home and I grab
a knife I still could end up in prison
if I killed them well depends what state
you live in 1,000% there's some crazy
laws I was just having this conversation
with someone like if somebody comes into
your house I forget what the law is
called we were talking about like some
case I forgot it's here stand your
ground law in Florida oh was I talking
to you probably who else did you talk to
stand your ground right right so like if
someone comes into your house and I
don't think they have it in New York and
like tries to steal any anything they're
on your property you can stand your
ground oh just what if they're just like
taking a look at your yard or something
you could just kill them well then you
know then it's up for the lawyers the
law becomes I yeah the law becomes a
little a little suspicious there but
like if somebody comes unto my property
with a weapon stand your ground you're
done you're done so that's what I'm
saying like I could end up in prison
like not by my own accord like I don't
plan on I'm not a criminal like it's not
in my it's not in my DNA what you're
saying is things happen things happen
like like okay let's say I'm in a bodega
and somebody comes in and holds up the
bodega like I'm I'm like I'm not going
to stand by and do nothing yeah well
where you live the Good Samaritan it
doesn't work out for you no like that
was that story of that Boda owner who
like literally somebody came in and like
tried to kill him and Rob his whole
store and he fought back he was like
this 90-year-old man it was like this
amazing heroic Story the whole thing was
caught in video he fought back and he
literally took the knife and like saved
his life and and and killed the guy and
he end up ended up in prison I was like
so that there were charges against him I
don't think he even killed the guy I
think he like just stabbed him and
defended himself there were charges
against him and he was like [__] this he
went back to his country yeah know
that's what I'm saying that was such an
upsetting story or that was like the
Marine that story like really galvanized
New York people were really upset also
the the on the
subway right something like that like I
don't plan on committing any crimes but
I could end up in prison and that's my
worst nightmare No Good Deed tury l yeah
no I'm just going to start mining my own
business which is so hard for me yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yeah a little pelaton fun obsessed
with this story Christopher Nolan
recalls getting roasted by his pelaton
instructor midw workout so Christopher
Nolan is writing a w of Acclaim thanks
to the success of Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer Oppenheimer the sweeping
biopic about the father of the atomic
bomb but you can't please all people all
the time while expecting the accepting
the award for best director um from the
New York film critic circle on Wednesday
night Nolan uh related an amusing story
of a recent criticism he received in an
unexpected Arena he said I was on my
pelaton doing a high interval workout
I'm dying the instructor started talking
about one of my films and said has
anyone else seen this because that's a
couple hours of my life I'll never get
back again so of course people went to
investigate which instructor which film
and it's most likely Jen Sherman who
said in a pelaton clip this song is from
a soundtrack of a movie be called tenant
anybody see this [__] did anybody see
this besides me because I need a manual
someone's got to explain this yeah I'm
not kidding what the [__] was going on
in that movie do you understand
seriously you need to be a
neuroscientist to understand and that's
two and a half hours of my life that I
want back LS so I'm obsessed with this
story for two reasons one because I
recently started following Jen Sherman
because I found out she's an enormous
toaster so her and I talk all the time
and second because when Cody rby was on
the to host I asked him I was like when
you're doing your classes do you ever
think about like how many pelons there
are and how many people have pelons in
their home and how how many of those
people like might be famous or like you
know someone important like you does
that ever cross your mind because it
would be all I think about like pelaton
is like a very upper echelon type of
thing it's a $2,000 bike like not anyone
could just buy it so you're definitely
like in this sort of elite class and I
said I'm like do you think about what
celebrity could be listening to your
class right now he's like honestly no
I've never thought of it and I was
shocked because like that's for me what
I would think about I never thought of
it for them either like when I used to
watch like he's always they're always
talking about celebrities cuz they're
always talking about music right like
he's always talking about Kelly Clarkson
it's like it never occurred to me does
Kelly do a Cody rsby ride to get down to
her own music by the way I just saw that
pelaton released like a whole new Kelly
Clarkson series got to get on my bike
like her catalog has been added oh my
God I have to get back on my pelaton I
haven't been on it in so long but like
I'm cleared I I could I
have done a Pelon like a few times now
because there's one in my gym in my
building it's like a communal one and I
made an account $40 a month my god um
loving it maybe I'll pelaton today if
you find a good Kelly Clarkson class
please share with the class I'm such a
good class curator that's really my
that's worse like sitting on that
[__] bike with that thing up your ass
looking for a class that's why I keep
doing the same class over and over on
the app on your phone before you get on
the bike you need to like get hyped
about classes
just to Ali love I really like her she's
just got this beautiful smile who Ali
love do you know her oh yes yes yes and
she does some country rides well I was
looking for a Taylor Swift class and she
had a 1989 one so I just like went with
it and I've literally only done that
class because every time I get on the
bike I'm like I'm not looking for
another class the one time I chose like
another class with a different
instructor was like a country I just
like hated it like it just was it's so
personal yeah you know what I also like
to do is treadmill classes you could do
it on a regular
treadmill and like it's like gives you
like running walking intervals and I
kind of like that Olivia Amato is the
girly swirly for that just the thing
with music is like it's so personal you
can trust me yeah yeah yeah see I've
actually been thinking cuz like weirdly
a lot of piltown instructors follow me
on social media like I will I will put
together especially when it comes to
Taylor Swift because there's her music
was just added and
honestly they could do better with the
selections like I really feel that way
and I know you need like fast songs slow
songs like I know you need it all like I
need to work with someone to create a
tayor shift class like it's what I only
do 30 minute classes it's seven songs
like not even six let me help you help
me help you or I mean the pelaton
community and the toaster Community like
the ven diagrams it's really just a
circle Jackie so I added # pellet
toaster to my account it's popping my
username I made like a really long time
ago I think during Co you like convinced
me to do some like five minute floor
workouts and so I just like made an
account um my account username is Theo's
Mom I made I I'll take that I made you
the account and I made that your did
yeah and Theo's mom yeah it's Theo's mom
I can't bring myself
to change it change it well you're still
Theo's mom yeah but I put hashtag pellet
toasters and I also put hashtag I stand
with Israel in my no it's so crazy how
everyone like gets so political on there
oh yeah no then I was looking because I
was just going to do Pell toaster but
I'm like let me see and like the most
popular ones are like moms who pellaton
teacher to teacher toners or whatever
like but then I was getting in there's
like political um like literally like
Republican Democrat pelaton like it's
crazy so I just put # pellet toaster and
# IAM with Israel but with the Taylor
Swift classic there's always a toaster
in it so when somebody high fives you
who also has hashtag pellet toaster like
there's nothing like that makes you feel
better no it's like when you're in the
class You' got to look you go to your
hashtag and you should like sometimes
I'll just run down and like highfive all
the pellet toasters so do you do a class
like that's happening live or like you
do pre-recorded ones is that a dumb
question I typically would do
pre-recorded when I was really into like
pelaton yeah then I would like get hype
for the new class but mostly
pre-recorded cuz I'm on my own timetable
yeah but try I like the idea of doing
like a pelaton walk Rod try it it's
really great and it's a it's a good
workout no I love that I think I'll do
that today love that for you anyway so
Christopher Nolan was watching pellaton
that's like so crazy and she started
talking trash about his film but it's
not crazy like no it's not pelaton is so
popular it's very expensive so you
really like Target like a an upper class
vibe and so like a a world-renowned
director having a bike like it it it it
tracks and it's just so unfortunate for
Jen Sherman she made a video responding
she was like like this [__] only happens
to me like I was it was honestly her
response was so funny but she was like
honestly I stand by what I said like I
did not understand one [__] minute of
that movie like the entire thing went
over my head I'm sure it was really good
like if you got it but I didn't get it
yeah no regts no RTS she said what she
said she said what she said but that's
just funny to think about you you know
that's it happens all the time with the
toast like we'll say we'll talk about
the most random person and like I never
even crosses my mind that they make pH
pH Philip Phillips and like I just I
could
die no we will talk about like the most
random people on the toast without even
thinking like that they will hear back
and nine times out of 10 like they send
us a message like Jack and I just
screenshot and send it to each other and
we just
died but cheeks just clench and I I
can't even read it want to go in a hole
like I don't even if I'm saying
something nice about someone like I
don't want them to hear it like that's
weird to me no I completely agree so I I
stand with Jen
German those were the fast five stories
but before we wrap up for the week and
for the day let's do our first ever
weenie of the week our weekly segment
where Jackie and I both nominate someone
to be the weenie of the week now being
weenie of the week means you did
something weenie-ish you're giving loser
is energy or you're just like it's out
the vibe you know so ja without further
ado who was your weenie of the week my
weenie of the week is still Claudine gay
nothing in this episode gave me a bigger
weenie than her the anti-semite the
plagiarist like she's got to go what's
so crazy is so she was fired she was the
dean of or president of Harvard and she
was uh she was forced to resign after
not even the anti-Semitism which we all
saw but like numerous uh instances of
plagiarism when it's like when you're in
college if you plagiarize anything
you're done biggest crime you're done so
like how are you going to have the head
of the institution who's a plagiarist
it's the biggest there's really nothing
worse you could do on a college campus
like in Academia than plagiarize yeah
because you could do something worse on
the college camp on the in AC in the
academic sphere in a literary sense in
yeah no in the course work yeah then
plagiarize so but still that was like
barely enough and she resigned but then
it turns out she's actually she's
resigned as president but she's still
going to be like working as a polyi
professor getting the same salary of
almost a million dollar a year she's
going to remain as a faculty member
making $900,000 a year unacceptable
she's a bit weenie she's definitely I
don't even want to nominate someone cuz
she's so weenie-ish but my weenie of the
week is different but it really it it my
ween of the week the person who who I'm
about to nominate like really
personifies the essence and the meaning
of the word weenie and it's chipsy Rose
Blanchard's ex-boyfriend like you
literally killed for her and she won't
even come visit you yeah like that's we
like you got played you got played but
she's the master player I know I guess
we're all just we and Gypsy world
yeah and what's the opposite of weenie
of the
week Queenie of the
week oh I love Gypsy Rose Blanchard
Queenie Queenie of the week is Gypsy
Rose Blanchard I have a feeling she's
goingon to be Queeny of the year but
stay tuned to find out the year is Young
you think she'll be time persons of the
year I think she should be I
agree all right well that's our show
it's so great to be back make sure to
like subscribe comment you know all the
things follow us oh at 300,000 followers
on Instagram if you love the show throw
us a a bone just follow us on Instagram
WE Post Great Clips there's really
nothing not to like if you are so
inclined just mute us just I just want
to reach 300,000 followers right like
295 or 296 so yeah the toast that's our
Instagram and I'm Jackie Asher if you
want to follow me good stuff happening
all the time if if you want to like
steal your boyfriend's phone like
seriously I mean it about what I said I
really want to reach 3,000 followers by
Monday so steal your boyfriend fiance or
husband's phone follow the toast and
then mute it so they'll never know that
you did that yeah yeah yeah yeah love
that mute make sure you mute stories and
posts but would that harm our engagement
if Instagram's like oh none of their
followers want to see their content
maybe nobody does that's an interesting
point we definitely we might get flagged
not flagged but Instagram will be like
oh maybe we should mute them for
everyone no that's a good point okay so
don't mute just
follow thanks so much for listening to
the to Millennium Morning Show where we
deliver the fast stories you need to
know every Monday Friday YouTube you're
watching us on YouTube please to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcast and
podcast be found on sptify
Bo listen to podcast find you been a
beautiful sing wickedly talented we are
have an amazing weekend we're back on
Monday love you bye love you
bye